I just had a question about how to
accept the fact that I don't really know
what I'm doing with my life um I I
didn't go to college and I don't feel
the need to go to college but I often
find it really hard to not feel
embarrassed about not going to college
because I feel like everyone in college
sports and toward something and while I
have a job and things like that I feel
like I'm working but not toward
something and I just I don't know how to
get there and I don't know how to not
feel embarrassed for people absolute awe
like what you do and you would pull and
I'm like no I don't and I just feel a
little judged every time I say that but
my mom had sirplease that her whole life
and I mean that is just not something I
like I think about you see and I just
really struggle with accepting the fact
that I don't know what I'm doing I don't
know what I wanted you and I feel really
pressured to figure it out and get all
my shape together like overnight and I I
guess I just want to know how can I make
this up to one accepting that not going
to college is just not for media not
feeling judged but also how do i how do
I figure this [ __ ] out you know I'm
Elise 21 is I don't know what I want to
do and really getting down to me well I
have bad news if you haven't figured it
out by age 21 Shanaya do not listen to
Josh well actually it made me think of
this essay I wrote a really long time
ago it's probably seven years ago six
seven years ago it's called when goals
are important and when they are not and
I'm gonna read a quick Center from those
will put a link to it in the show notes
as well people have all sorts of clever
words to describe what they do what they
want to do objective target plan in game
outcome goal if you know me then you
know I was the goal guy when I was in
the
corporate world I had financial goals
health goals sales goals vacation goals
even consumer purchase goals I [ __ ] you
not
I had spreadsheets of goals precisely
tracking and measuring and readjusting
my plans accordingly these days life is
different and I no longer want any goals
in my life instead instead of an
arbitrary target I prefer to have a
direction in which I travel if you're
searching for a sunrise it's important
to be headed east for a sunset west I do
however believe there was a time in my
life and goals were direly important
when I was in a hole and needed to get
out truth be told most of my goals were
ridiculous or irrelevant purchasing and
accumulation goals for example but a few
of my goals helped immensely like
getting out of debt or losing all that
weight I lost like 80 pounds I like it a
lot of goals - escaping a crater in the
middle of a desert when I was fat enough
to my eyeballs in debt lingering in that
bowl-shaped cavity my goal was to break
free from the sun-scorched Basin and
fine Earth's surface and so I tended to
I'll skip the rest of the essay here but
I tend to delineate between goals Ryan
you and I often talk about when to
extend
TK's point about Elijah's question we
talk about raising our standards below
in our expectations and I think one way
to maybe reframe that for some folks is
instead of having a goal have a
direction in which you want to travel
right you're living in Dayton Ohio and
yeah instead of I want to end up in LA
maybe it's I want to go west you know
who knows maybe you'll end up in San
Diego or Seattle and that'll be a better
experience for you and you're not so
tethered to whatever that outcome might
be I think sometimes however the
outcomes are important but in a Shanaya
case it doesn't tell if she has a
massive amount of debt she doesn't have
all this weight to lose there isn't this
crater from which she needs to escape
the crater she needs to escape from
right now is a self-imposed crater she's
feeling the pressure but I think most of
that pressure maybe 99% of it is
internal pressure and by the way the
external pressure that she's feeling if
someone is truly judging you like
Oh can't believe Shania is not going to
college and racking up all that debt
can't believe she's 21 years old and
doesn't have a figured out yeah I mean
that those people are not just
unreasonable but but they their
expectations are their own they don't it
doesn't mean they have to be your
expectations you know it may when you
were talking about you know the
standards versus expectations or maybe
you know changing direction I think
about how you know you and I have been
talking about this book I've been
working on and yes my outcome is like
man I really would like to finish this
book however that that outcome is not
really it's not really driving me to get
the book finished so what you and I
talked about a couple weeks ago is all
right man just look at it as setting
three hours aside one hour three
different days schedule it in your
calendar and start working on the book
just start there with three hours in
that just in the last two weeks has it's
just helped me focus and in what you
told me to is like as soon as that hour
runs up stop stop Vincennes yeah I don't
keep going but but I guess what I'm
trying to share here is that yes like
there is an outcome that I want there is
I guess you could say it's a goal but I
have kind of removed that goal and have
changed my approach so now it's about
raising my standards in the sense that
I'm working on this thing consistently I
can look in the mirror and say yes Ryan
you've put at least three hours into it
this week and that will eventually help
me to get to that outcome that I want
but but it's kind of removed that
pressure for myself to have it all
figured out right now when we talk about
raising your standards lower your
expectations I think you've maybe
intentionally or maybe even
unintentionally that's this is what
happens with standards that they tend to
raise on their own what you're getting
good at something you raise your
standard because when we first had the
conversation it was two hours it was one
hour twice a week basically and stop at
that one hour but if you can do three
that means you've raised your standard I
mean you're talking about 50% increase
productivity I'll say one other thing
I'll let TK jump in here but Lao sue he
he said a good traveler has no fixed
plans and is not intent on arriving I
think the book writing process is often
that way with me I started since writing
everything that remains I've started
four different books and none of them
have turned into books but I haven't
been intent on arriving and they they I
knew when to stop or not even stop but
when to set it aside and start over or
start something new and it's because my
standards are really high and the
process of writing for me is in many
ways the reward going through through
that writing process for me is that is
the the outcome you know in many ways is
just sitting down in the chair and doing
the work and if it if it manifests into
something later then that's great tell
me I'm wrong TK here I'm curious you
guys ever felt like that like I have no
idea where I'm going oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean I well it depends I mean I
think I feel like that on little things
all the time even now I feel that now
like not every single day but there are
moments where I'm like well that what
the hell are we doing where we go right
and and I think part of that has to do
with not being comfortable with where we
are right now and and and it goes back
to that crater thing for me right like
sometimes we we are in these real
craters I had it's close to half a
million dollars worth of debt in my late
20s and and that I knew I needed to go
to that and having a goal to get out of
that was was important to me but it
wasn't nearly as important it's actually
doing the work to get out of it like the
goal could be fun we could all have the
goal to be debt-free but so what if you
don't do the work to actually get there
yeah
you